es gab diese idee eine gruppe
außergewöhnlicher leute
zusammenzubringen
wir wollten damit etwas großes schaffen
es gibt leute die finden alle
superhelden filme gut aber leute die
justice league schlecht finden eher ja
wirklich sehr schlecht ist wenn den hier
super das fühlt sich an wie die
götterdämmerung bei wagner das heißt das
ist jetzt der teil der wto das ist der
teil der fenster ist das ist der teil wo
sich bewähren muss diese arbeit an den
caritas die sie halt gemacht haben ein
paar filme lang das heißt wenn man die
leiden kann dann tut es einem natürlich
auch weh oder macht anders aus wenn sie
durch die mangel gedreht werden und ich
glaube das funktioniert das problem ist
wenn man mehrere dieser film gesehen hat
kann man natürlich nicht mehr wirklich
entscheiden wie das leuten geben wird
für die dass der erste film ist man kann
sich aber vorstellen dass es leute gibt
für die dass der letzte film ist und die
dann mit offenem mund drin sitzen und
den schönen satz sagen die man ja auch
bei serien solid
das machen die jetzt nicht mehr das
machen wir jetzt nicht das geht doch
nicht reden wir kurz über seinen plan
können wir schon so machen aber dann ist
seit kacke lieber mache ich den plan
dann wird es auch was also es hat ein
paar jahre gedauert es geht los mit
allmend zwei würde ich sagen so richtig
das dieses world building stattfindet
das eben auch geklappt hat und der trick
war natürlich man muss da irgendeine
bedrohung finden die ein grund hergibt
maßstabsgetreue sozusagen alle anderen
in diesem kampf rein zu ziehen und das
hat man geschafft nämlich sein muss
kronberg wäre die erfahren wie es ist zu
verlieren fest daran zu glauben im recht
zu sein und trotzdem zu scheitern
wenn das ist ein geisteskranker ein
monat des planeten titan der zum
beispiel seine eigene mutter umgebracht
für medizinische experimente und so was
also niemand den man jetzt irgendwie als
schwiegersohn haben will aber josh
brolin gibt dem ein ziemlich gutes
gesicht und stalin hat ihn erfunden
73 das war so einer der marvel autoren
die verstanden haben dass man mit comics
alles machen kann und alles und vor
allem sehr viel schlimmes passiert dann
in diesem film so lange ich ihn kenne
hatte er immer nur ein ziel
[Musik]
das halbe universum machen schaden kann
es nicht wenn man es schon kennt des mci
des marvel universe aber ob's hilft weiß
ich tatsächlich nicht weil ich sie kenne
ich kann mir aber folgendes vorstellen
es gibt ja diese weltmeisterschaften im
werk an die meisten dominosteine
aufstellen und dann wird geschmückt und
dann geht es eine halbe stunde bis die
alle umgefallen sind und wer sowas gerne
an guckt aber mit personen mit
geschichte mit schauspielerischen
leistungen also wenn es bald vorbei
die werden also durch gewischt und geben
ihr jeweils bestes wer sowas mag der mag
das ich bin übrigens später doctor
strange o
ihr benutzt eure künstlernamen dann bin
ich spiderman das witzige ist eine
handschrift also die bewusste brüder
schon interviews haben den film gemacht
eine handschrift kann man da glaube ich
inzwischen nicht mehr finden weil es
tatsächlich so eine gattung marvel film
gibt und die kann man besser oder
schlechter erfüllen oder so dass man sie
eben ein bisschen belastet und hier wird
sie belastet man merkt aber bei dieser
belastung der gattung dass sie natürlich
dann doch eingehalten wird insofern als
jetzt nichts passiert was sozusagen das
schauen wir zerbricht das wird halt
verboten aber es ist wie mit komik
buster keaton hat mal gesagt im
gegenstand zu verbiegen ist
interessanter und lustiger als ihn zu
zerbrechen und das passiert das wird
eine ganz schöne plätze
[Musik]
infinity ward